[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
où nous allons parler évidemment de
l'actualité mais surtout de
l'information de la formation chez des
jeunes chez les lycéens notamment
peut-être des notions de complotisme de
fake news
et pour en parler en plateau maryse
bruce taille bonjour vous êtes de
professeur d'histoire à mantes-la-jolie
au lycée saint-exupéry
vous êtes mort du clemi c'était un
organisme qui s'occupe justement 20,2 de
problème de la formation vis-à-vis des
dix séries donc on va en parler
évidemment avec vous florence mercadé le
choc et bonjour aux agents patrice
avocate au barreau de versailles ce
déchaînement son professeur à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
et puis en visio avec nous rémy en grand
bonjour bonjour vous êtes directeur de
cabinet de la communication de la maire
de chanteloup les vignes et vous un
spécialiste de ce qu'on appelle parfois
peut-être attendre les quartiers
difficiles on va dire les quartiers et
justement le problème de la formation la
désinformation est très important dans
nos c'est une cartier vincent couronne
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le fondateur
du des surligneurs donc vous faites très
attention à ce qu'ils disent qu'en
défèque news notamment dans le dans le
vocabulaire politique et puis vous
faites un podcast sur l'europe et sur
les idées reçues et les idées fausses
répondu notamment sur l'europe
j'enchaîne lajoinie bonjour vous êtes
d'où vous êtes vous êtes aux enseigner
aussi à l'iut de rambouillet donc vous
êtes confrontés vous aussi à des
étudiants et parfois justement à
s'effectue au genou à cette
désinformation
alors avant d'en parler peut-être que un
élément d'actualité mais qui partent
très
et les éloigner de cela c'est la tribune
qui est parue dans la presse pour
défendre
charlie hebdo ensemble défendons la
liberté avec cette phrase d'ailleurs en
défendant les libertés de place fait
mais ce n'est pas le blasphème que nous
défendons mais la liberté
j'ai commencé par voumard is bruce
taille est ce que par exemple ce procès
qui a lieu actuellement
c'est un événement qui fait parler vos
élèves honnêtement on en n'a pas disputé
en classes et les élèves que moi j'ai un
luxe et actuellement ils ont entre 15 et
18 ans donc il dit pour les ceux qui
sont en seconde et j'étais en cm2 à
l'époque oui
donc ils sont moins concernés que les
générations précédentes avec lesquels on
a effectivement beaucoup échangé en
classe lâche j'ai vraiment pas eu
l'occasion d'en discuter avec eux je
pense que c'est moins important que ce
n'était pour les pour les plus âgés il
ya 55 ans par contre c'est quelque chose
de très brûlants dont on a beaucoup
parlé effectivement il peut s'il fallait
parier absolument d'ailleurs qui était
pas évident à traiter parce que c'était
beaucoup beaucoup d'émotion beaucoup de
choses à traiter en classe mais il ya
cinq ans effectivement dix élèves
étaient très intéressés par ce n'est pas
l'actualité comme nous tous d'ailleurs
bien sûr mais on avait parfois que dans
des justement dans l'est dans certains
établissements il y avait une minute de
silence notamment qui avaient dû être
observées il y avait des des élèves
notamment qu'ils refusaient d'observer 7
minutes et si vous avez confrontation ne
pas être confronté je pense que c'était
davantage en collèges qu'en lycées
moi j'étais en lice et j'ai eu la chance
de pas y être confrontés mais
effectivement ça a existé ce qui est ce
qui était très compliqué surtout c'est
que le bas les enseignants n'étaient pas
formés à ce type d'événement donc
c'était déjà une charge émotionnelle
forte pour n'importe qui et en plus
amorcé un échange avec des élèves qui
eux aussi sont choqués on n'a pas du
tout l'habitude d'autant plus si ces
élèves là il avait déjà des comédiens
des idées sur sur charlie hebdo par
exemple on s'était très très compliqué à
l'époque
aujourd'hui on a un petit peu mieux
préparés et encore mais effectivement
oui à l'époque il a fallu qu'on en
discute et ce n'était pas toujours
facile
ouais c'est pas de boussole alors
évidemment vous pour vous enseigner à
l'université
forcément vous n'allez pas parler
d'actualité
avec des élèves mais ça peut arriver sur
les étudiants oui c'est le droit c'est
tellement oui oui c'est tellement vaste
qu'on peut raccrocher
d'une manière ou d'une autre toujours
une question de lier des problèmes de
droit d'ailleurs dans une question
juridique il ya évidemment la question
fondamentale de la liberté d'opinion et
d'expression bien entendu oui nous en
avons parlé à l'époque et nous en
reparlons au moins incidemment ce moment
nous en avions parlé à l'époque en
organisant des débats il entendu jean
charles lajoie ni je crois que vous vous
même vous avez eu des débats sur ces sur
ces sujets avec vos étudiants absolument
nous on en parle quotidiennement 1
puisque je m'occupe de communication et
de culture générale donc bien évidemment
on en parle on organise des débats c'est
toujours passionnant
quelquefois impressionnant tant le
certains étudiants sont totalement
déconnectés de la vie réelle il ya des
étudiants qui ne sont pas c'est pas la
majorité bien comme des étudiants qui ne
sont pas au courant du procès de charlie
hebdo par exemple ça leur passe
totalement au dessus de la dalle est il
concerné 2 en deuxième année
effectivement les choses s'améliorent
considérablement mais effectivement
c'est quelque chose dont on parle sans
arrêt sans arrêt sans arrêt et bleu
le vrai problème est un problème qui est
effectivement sur cette idée de
blasphème et beaucoup d'eux beaucoup
d'étudiants sont sont choqués par le
fait qu'on puisse critiquer une religion
et donc vous expliquer ce que les
défenses entre une religion une personne
etc
ça donne ça donne lieu à des choses
intéressantes et et honnêtement dit
toujours que les débats n'apporte pas
grand chose en tout cas avec les
étudiants je pense que ces débats
apporte énormément parce que la
situation s'améliore notablement une
fois qu'on a pu discuter et expliquer
beaucoup les choux donc ça c'est très
important
j'ajoute juste une petite chose c'est
que et madame qui est là sur mon idée là
dessus je suis absolument abasourdi par
le une sorte de méconnaissance totale
des étudiants quand ils arrivent après
leur bac en fin de l'arc de terminale
ils ont quasiment jamais lu de journaux
ils n'ont aucun accès la presse ne
savent même pas que ça existait là là je
pense qu'il ya un problème si
d'enseignement secondaire et que les
professeurs ne doivent pas baisser les
bras
c'est le rôle des profs de dire aux
élèves que au delà de 2
on va parler défectueuse tout à l'heure
mais qu'au-delà de l'effectif et des
journaux et que qu'ils soient de droite
ou de gauche soit le figaro ou
libération n'est pas de techno dans ses
journaux et c'est ça qu'il faut lire pas
arrêter un peu cette culture du deux des
trois lignes sur un téléphone portable
qui est actuellement en concert on va en
parler tout à l'heure parce que c'est
peut-être par là que viennent en effet
la désinformation les fake news et le
complotisme mais justement c'est tout le
rôle du duc les murs et quitte donc le
centre de liaison de l'enseignement et
des médias d'information
c'est justement d'éveiller les élèves à
la lecture des journaux à la formation
d'un tout à fait oui alors est-ce que ce
que j'entendais en fait la presse écrite
est effectivement beaucoup moins lus par
les élèves que je vois c'est ça c'est
une évidence
après sur l'accès à la presse dans les
seconds appelle les cdi qui sont comme
des médiathèques temps mais dans les
établissements ya encore de la presse
écrite dont qu'ils y ont accès après
c'est aussi aux enseignants nous y
emmener de l'est de les faire fréquenter
moi je vais régulièrement je demande à
mes élèves de faire des revues de presse
ou qui rendent analystes et experts des
autres articles donc ça arrive mais
c'est vrai que ce qui est sûr c'est que
ce n'est pas une pratique récurrente et
régulière des élèves
la presse écrit petit lycée la presse
locale ces parisiens
et puis la presse le sport ça c'est
encore 2 ou deux types de presse écrite
que je constate encore un petit peu lus
par les élèves effectivement après ils
s'informent sur les réseaux sociaux donc
ils ne vont pas forcément lire un
article entier
et puis ces charges aux clés mis
effectivement de proposer aux
professeurs et donc aux élèves de
fréquenter les différents types de
médias est d'être dans la pluralité des
médias quand même comme elle existe
aujourd'hui réunion grange revient donc
à cette tribune sur la liberté de la
presse
est-ce que chanteloup les vignes les
jeunes que vous côtoyez cc sont
intéressés par le par exemple le procès
qui a lieu actuellement ou est ce que ça
leur paraît un peu lointain non ça ne
m'avait pas loin du tout c'est c'est une
problématique qui revient très souvent
très souvent sur tapis moi j'en parle
avec avec des habitants et des
associatifs avec des élus aussi inquiets
ils sont âgés de moins de 30 ans et qui
peuvent avoir un rapport du coup un peu
différent aux médias traditionnels parce
qu'effectivement tout le monde en parle
mais le rapport aux médias la façon dont
on consomme et donc les utilisateurs de
médias a profondément modifié aussi le
rapport à l'expression on est à la fois
émetteur et récepteur
il ya parfois si une forme de sentiment
d'impunité
quand on quand on quand on émet des
messages donc il y avait à la fois je
dirais alors pour répondre à votre
question une dimension qui est celle
d'un sentiment d'un discours médiatique
à deux vitesses il ya toujours le
sentiment d'avoir date d'être d'être
dans un enfermé dans une forme de
clichés le cas une forme de
victimisation qui est qui revient ainsi
régulièrement c'est-à-dire on parle
toujours de nous en mal les à côtés il
ya aussi il sage les essais en vol a
vécu il ya pas très longtemps avec à
chanteloup les vignes avec l'expérience
d'un bar youtuber dont on a beaucoup
parlé là dans la presse qui qui a soigné
des dizaines de milliers de messages à
caractère insultant agressif appels à la
haine en se cachant derrière quelque
part un statut youtuber vos produisant
mais attendez moi c'est mon gagne pain
je fais ça ainsi vous rigolez c'est du
lourd mais en réalité il ya il ya un
cadre à la liberté d'expression et c'est
ça qu'il faut expliquer le premier de la
première finalement le premier cadre à
faire passer aux jeunes et aux moins
jeunes c'est déjà de confirmer qu'il est
bien un cadre à la liberté d'expression
et quand on parle de charlie hebdo le
sentiment c'est oui mais regardez le
peuvent tout se permettre
alors que nous bah oui sauf qu'en même
temps que cheikh guèye non on est
vraiment dans le cadre de la liberté
d'expression donc en fait il ya un gars
vraiment je pense que du coup monsieur
couronne nous apportera un éclairage sur
le sujet mais il ya vraiment une
une réflexion que je leur ai dit que
finalement avoir au départ pour bien
comprendre que contenu ou veut dire
beaucoup de choses dans ce pays on peut
également place fait mais on peut
également faire de lui
court mais à un moment il y avait
toujours ses limites de l'atteinte à
l'intégrité de l'autre l'atteinte à
l'intégrité morale physique de l'eau
justement vincent couronne alors
peut-être aborder le problème juridique
avec stéphane mon sens et florence
mercadé aussi on a eu la récemment un
par exemple un rappeur qui a tenu dès
qu'il fait des textes très antisémite
presque négationnistes est ce que la
liberté d'expression ça dépend du lieu
où s'expriment pas ce que lui après tout
peut dire je suis un artiste et voilà
c'est de la création de la même façon
que charlie hebdo dit moi je suis un
journal et j'ai je le droit dont brad
blasphémer mais peut-être qu'un individu
youtuber comment parler rémy un gant
c'est un peu différent est ce que est ce
que le point de vue des opales est
important mais oui i patrice le point de
vue dont on parle et il a son importance
parce que déjà ça permet de savoir de
l'acquis qui va entendre ce point de vue
est ce qu'il ya plus ou moins de monde
parce que c'est cadre privé le cadre
public donc ça déjà il ya une différence
pour ce qui est de la qualification la
diffamation par exemple ou d'atteinte à
l'honneur sur deux choses mais de
manière générale c'est quand on est dans
le cadre de la liberté d'expression il
me semble que là l'endroit d'où l'on
part d'être important aussi parce que ça
termine
quel est le ton que l'on va utiliser si
on est charlie hebdo on sait qu'on fait
la carrière de la caricature et la
satire
si on est le monde dont ses conseils
d'informations sérieuses et c'est ce qui
n'empêche pas d'avoir la caricature dans
le monde mais dans un cadre qui lui est
réservé on avait eu ce débat
précédemment par rapport à valeurs
actuelles qui avait une image de danièle
obono l'a écoutée en esclaves
bon ça pose des problèmes parce que ce
n'était pas dans un cadre dans ce
journal a réservé à la caricature
c'était un article d'information et donc
sa 500 important pour savoir si oui ou
non on insulte
oui ou non on dépasse les bornes et sert
à la liberté d'expression voilà ça me et
puis quand il quand il s'agit de
créateurs dont les artistes l'arbre 106
me divertit quasiment totale
enfin ça c'est une opinion très
personnel mais donc donc là qu'on peut
pas on pourra peut-être en parle un peu
plus tout à l'heure mais voilà ça c'est
mon la façon dont je conçois les choses
vont terminer sur ce sujet florence et
où est la limite à cette liberté
d'expression a été extrêmement bien
exprimer mais le fait d'avoir des propos
racistes des propos antisémites des
propos sexistes sont aussi condamnée par
par le code pénal
mais même si c'est arrivé des rappeurs
qu'ils soient condamnés non voilà pour
la nation donc lorsqu'on est un artiste
que toute force et on a tout n'est pas
permis
la liberté d'expression dans l'histoire
de leurs moyens d'encadrement quand même
il faut pas tomber dans des propos qui
peuvent être attaqués de manière sur le
plan pénal
ok voilà oui et 2 pas de sens de la
patrie ce prix là effectivement quelque
chose que j'ai pas apprécié que j'ai pas
précisé mais même si on est charlie
hebdo effectivement il ya des mythes
pénale à ce qu'on peut dire ça parce
qu'on est un journal satirique on peut
tout dire c'est évidemment sur des
condamnations ou des procès en tout cas
on va il ya un autre
un autre fait médiatique qui a fait
couler beaucoup d'encre récemment qui
est quand même l affaire de cette jeune
femme de l'unef voilée qui est du coup
qui a fait la une des journaux avec des
dt auditionné donc à l'assemblée
nationale et de national il a débuté est
parti parce qu'elle avait le voilà c est
exactement voilà typiquement typiquement
un fait médiatique
là on va parler d'islam mais on sait
aussi que l'islam vit aussi dans les
temps les quartiers au fauga ya
énormément de joie que cette confession
musulmane dans les quartiers typiquement
là il ya une incompréhension c'est à
dire d'un côté on va avoir ce fait se
fait là ce phénomène là avec des députés
qui vont prendre qui m'en prendre là
cette décision de quitter la salle sous
prétexte la personne à un voile et puis
de l'autre côté il ya le lie à charlie
hebdo est donc une perception
extrêmement j'irai étriqué aussi du
débat sur sur charia sur charlie hebdo
donc quelque part dans les quartiers
c'est juste pour répondre encore plus
précisément la question et des quartiers
comme chanteloup-les-vignes céderait
pour mantes la jolie et c'est finalement
quand on écoute les jeunes quand on
écoute les habitants et pour la pression
d'être tiraillé entre des extrêmes sur
le suggérer sur sept et grande arène que
son quels sont les dégâts et et sait
jamais vraiment à leur avantage
voilà et donc il ya comme un sentiment
de deux poids deux mesures mais jeudi
bien que c'est un sentiment de deux
poids deux mesures mais c'est ce sur
quoi précisément il faut travailler
aujourd'hui travailler travers de
l'éducation médias voilà je suis juste
un mot je suis quand même temps après
inquiète par le sens même de votre
question quand on commence à se demander
si la liberté d'expression peut être à
géométrie variable
c'est extrêmement inquiétant et quand
vincent couronne mélange valeurs
actuelles avec le reste en disant que
valeurs actuelles c'était un papier de
l'information c'est totalement faux
puisque c'était une fille ont été
sélectionnés steria était un faux avec
donc ça bastia 3 1 2 donc cet argument
ne tient absolument pas et la liberté
d'expression florence mercan et et
stéphane mention en sont les témoins
c'est parfaitement balisé il ya des lois
on sait ce qu'on a le droit de dire ad
on ne peut pas être raciste antisémite
ni sexiste négationniste c'est
parfaitement définis et c'est très bien
le reste n'a pas de l'endroit pour la
liberté d'expression et d'en bas on
devrait limiter sa liberté les
craquements c'est le début de la fin ce
serait une catastrophe
il faut on ne peut pas accepter même
cette formule sont là et c'est un
endroit pour la liberté d'expression
n'ont bien évidemment tu as compris bien
cette enquête qui a été ouverte sur ce
sur ce sujet et on verra ce qu'ils
jugent qu'un mot sur la question du
voile à l assemblée stéphane manceau
peut-être aussi il faudrait se confirmer
un moment à la loi c'est dire qu'il ya
des endroits où en effet le voile est
permis deux roues il n'est pas là en
l'occurrence il était autorisé monsieur
petit nom il n'était pas interdit donc
ça signifie qu'ils voient leur est
autorisé mais le le le mais l'opération
a parfaitement réussi de la part de
cette responsable du syndicat unef moi
ce qui me m'interroge au delà il est
tombé sur des deux côtés une posture et
imposture des deux côtés et ce qui
m'interroge au delà de tous ces deux en
effet ça a été souligné à maintes
reprises c'est de voir qu'en l'espace
d'une quinzaine d'années ce que l'unef
est devenu avec eux la numéro 2 ou porte
parole de l'unef de pas rien qui
apparaît vous allez est salée les gens
qui avaient adhéré à l'union
ils sont nombreux à ne pas en croire
leurs yeux qui étaient étaient très
proches du parti gaulliste vous vous
vous diront qu'ils étaient très bien
j'ai plein de souvenirs
et puis d'une conception carrément
j'allais enfin beaucoup plus que la xfr
nati religieuse il y avait il y avait
une position très très radicale un mot
sur l'interdiction du voile au cours du
mois de septembre
il ya une jeune avocate qui a voulu
prêter serment avec le voile qui en a
été interdite
le conseil de l'ordre le conseil de
l'ordre a interdit le fait qu'elle
puisse prêter serment avec un voile elle
a fait appel de cette décision est la
décision était confirmée par la cour
d'appel disant qu'il ne faut pas
mélanger
en l'espèce dans un tribunal sa
profession avec des convictions des
convictions religieuses
s'il ya deux justices auxiliaires de
justice police et la justice
très bien alors on va parler justement
de cofidis est le premier thème de cette
émission le composent
et justement les jeunes je vais vous
demander comment vous vous anna et nu
vous êtes nombreuses heures d'histoire
je rappelle que vous êtes venu à vous
intéresser justement au problème de la
formation et peut-être aussi de la thèse
d'information chez des jeunes bat
déborde d'abord c'est les disciplines
que j'enseigne qui sont ralliés à la
fois qualité donc l'histoire géographie
et puis elle pendant ce qui s'appelle
l'enseignement moral et civique
il ya aussi le fait que ça fait presque
20 ans que j'enseigne j'ai toujours des
déserts en face de moi qui ont le même
âge mais qui change chaque année
et donc il faut toujours à se mettre à
jour sur leurs pratiques informationnel
qui ont largement été modifié et donc
pour ça il faut échanger avec eux
comment vous vous informez ou vous
informer
et puis pour que l'aic depuis 2015 à une
plus grande place qui est faite à
l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information dans l'est dans
l'enseignement et dans les programmes
ça a été reconnue par la loi sur la
refondation de l'école comme une
compétence transversale ça veut dire que
tous les enseignants peuvent s'en
emparer problème c'est qu'il faut
trouver le temps dans les programmes qui
sont très lourdes de le faire il ya des
programmes qui ont vraiment mis des
thèmes d'éducation aux médias et à
l'information
à l'ordre du jour donc moi je vais
étudier avec mes élèves de première en
enseignement moral et civique
les réseaux sociaux et la fabrique de
l'information donc on va parler de biais
de confirmation de bulles de philips
qu'on va parler de surinformation de tri
de validité on va parler de complotisme
aussi ça c'est un autre thème qu'on va
aborder complotisme révisionnisme un peu
plus historique et1 fox puisque c'est le
mot qu'on utilise pour pour les faits
que nous donc à une place dans les
programmes prof de lettres aussi on est
un thème sur sa forme et déforme et il
ya aussi une spécialité qui a été créé
avec la réforme du lycée
alors elle est un peu longue c'est
l'histoire géographie géopolitique
sciences politiques il ya un thème sur
s'informer un regard critique sur les
sources d'information de communication
donc il ya une place qui est faite maman
peut davantage avoir l'occasion de
traiter ça avec les élèves mais
justement question je vous pose b quand
on est sensible aux thèses du petit
bourg fait 12 etc
vous êtes professeur d'histoire c'est
pas souvent parce que on a une mauvaise
chute du riz story alors savoir fidéles
complotistes auquel on adhère et parfois
c'est effectivement patients par manque
de connaissance par exemple les
illuminati je rappelle chaque fois aux
élèves
quand on fait la française que oui ils
ont existé mais seulement entre eux 1776
et 1986 a voilà mais effectivement ce
qu'on reproche souvent à des erreurs
historiques et qu'on fait patauger avec
la formation du jour où après cherche à
charrat nous enseignants et
particulièrement une histoire géographie
effectivement de donner ce bagage
culturel hydrique aux élèves mais de
toute façon ils ne connaissent pas
forcément en étudiant en classe donc on
peut pas leur en vouloir à eux en tout
cas de faire des erreurs sur l'histoire
qu'on n'a pas encore étudié
c'est vrai qu'ici c'est bien peut-être
de mêler les deux c'est à dire d'avoir à
la fois l'enseignement historique et
puis peut-être quelque chose qui est
plus proche d'eux
c'est à dire la formation qui peuvent
voir notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
il y avait un sondage qui est paru il ya
deux ans je crois qui est inquiétant que
79% des français croient au moins à une
théorie conspirationniste
c'est quand même incroyable le sauvage
et d'impôts non mais sans patrice fait
bien qu'on ne nous dit pas tout même sur
[Rires]
yat il une émission actuellement est-ce
qu'on est là oui parce qu'on n'est pas
là rim et aux grands lestement sur ces
ses thèses complotistes
oui tout simplement est ce que est ce
que vous en attendez vous beaucoup qui
ce qui se répandent
parce que parfois il ya des défaites du
ski peuvent qui peuvent provoquer des
agitations aux très fortes dans des
quartiers notamment
oui alors déjà pour commencer je dirais
que le phénomène défectueuse et du
conspirationnisme touche pas uniquement
les quartiers populaires à travers ce
voilà tous les territoires
après il est vrai aussi que sur des
territoires plus en difficulté le
terreau est peut-être plus fertile pour
que celle-ci théorie la prospère
notamment s'appuyant sur ce que je
décrivais auparavant c'est-à-dire des
sentiments de relégation le sentiment
d'être un citoyen de seconde zone et
donc très facilement on en arrive je
suis là
victime d'un grand système qui agit et
luttent quotidiennement contre moi alors
après ça s'exprime
ça s'explique dans les petites choses du
quotidien ça peut s'exprimer évidemment
sur des lectures de et commande lecture
finalement des rapports de force de la
société ça s'exprime aussi sur vous et
sur des petites rumeurs en réalité et on
en revient finalement toujours à ce
débat sur sur les réseaux sociaux et sur
comment on arrive à contrôler ou moins
encadrées à l'ats l'information on avec
des exemples à chanteloup les vignes de
rumeurs qui sont partis est à peu près
rien un petit post sur facebook un tweet
on commence à laisser penser par exemple
qu'un qu'un petit point camionnette se
promène dans la rue qui va enlever les
enfants des familles etc
et puis très rapidement on se retrouve
et qu'un postier qui est pris à partie
dans sa camionnette par des gens mais
physiquement parce que le message a fait
le tour du quartier et que les habitants
réellement l'impression qui va lui
arriver quelque chose alors il ya
toujours un fond de vérité dans la
rumeur mais on l'escaladent 68 l'audible
en tout cas si c'est pas vrai c'est
toujours vrai il ya une sorte de vrais
semblables jeanneret semblable en effet
et nous du coup en tant que communicant
mais pour ce que l'on voit en réalité
parce qu'il ya énormément de deux thèses
qui circule sur les réseaux que moi je
vois pas que personne ici une voire 1 il
ya le snap shot aujourd'hui en plus
permet de dire des choses qui
disparaissent enfin ça va ça ça va très
très vite sur ce qu'on veut ce qu'on
peut voir on est du coup note en
communicant public
et là je parlerai vraiment mon
expérience professionnelle très souvent
amené à rectifier de l'information en
temps réel et sa voix aussi pour voilà
pour des informations qui concernent
aussi des projets qui sont qui sont
lancés par la collectivité un oui mais
voilà si on sort un peu du champ du
conspirationnisme mais on reste quand
même toujours sur celui de la
représentation de la perception
l'information et la nécessité d'accorder
géant en temps réel ça se passe à la
fois à l'école évidemment avec le
travail tu peux faire le clemi et les
enseignants et les enseignants au
quotidien ça passe aussi par le travail
que nous comme une écran
public pouvons faire au quotidien pour
gérer objective et une information qui
très souvent avec le poids de l'affect
devient devient distordue quoi là il ya
une théorie du complot la corne entendu
ces derniers temps avec les le port du
masque avec les vaccinations oui si on
veut nous faire vacciner c'est parce que
le virus a été développé par l'industrie
pharmaceutique il va gagner de l'argent
en faisant des vaccins etc
on a entendu on a cité les illuminati 1
kg pas pourquoi les illuminatis je pense
que ça vient du davinci code je pense
que ça vient de là qui a répondu parce
que personne ne parle des illuminati
jean-charles vous ayez raison
enfin les régions je pense le le le non
c'est vrai que le le fait de se fier
parce qu'on appelle les internet permet
et de répondre plus facilement de fox
news que si on se sent tenait en effet à
la presse écrite ou peut-être à la radio
à la télévision
absolument moi ce que je fais toujours
en course est elle une sorte d'ordre que
se donne la ccl même pas un conseil
c'est que zack information qui est
délivrée par les étudiants dans un
exposé dans un devoir dans une soute
nord doit toujours être source aie aie
aie aie source et de deux manières
différentes d'arc en aucun cas je ne
peux accepter un chiffre qui vient d'un
site internet à piment inconnue et c'est
ce que j'apprends aux étudiants c'est
vraiment ok vous entendez parler quelque
chose il ya des journaux il ya des sites
sérieux il ya des sites qu'on peut
recommander presque labellisés et voilà
c'est cela qu'il faut pas donc une fois
qu'on a dit ça c'est une sorte de
mécanisme que les que les étudiants
intègrent parfaitement et il découvre qu
effectivement il ya des des sources
d'information qui sont fiables et
d'autres qui ne sont même pas alors
laissez pas très grave quand il s'agit
de savoir connaître le tour de taille de
kim kardashian c'est pas très grave mais
sur le sur des problèmes vraiment en
changer effectivement et il sait en
utilisant tous maintenant pris
l'habitude et prenda s'est vite
l'habitude effectivement deux
de vérifier de sources et l'information
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui
fonctionne et comme le disait madame
tout à l'heure c'est vrai que dans les
bibliothèques et à la bibliothèque de
rambouillet il ya des journaux en accès
libre
et il ya surtout pour tous les étudiants
et j'imagine c'est pas que à rambouillet
et bien évidemment enfin je le sais ils
ont tous accès à toute la presse
gratuitement sur tout sur leur
ordinateur
donc il n'y a aucune raison il n'ya pas
il n'y a pas cette excuse de dire je
n'ai pas l'argent
l'intérim ici c'est gratuit c'est l'idée
qui enfin le ps qui nous offre cet accès
donc voilà maintenant formation elle est
totalement libre en france et pour les
étudiants elle est gratuite donc aucune
et qu'il va pas là la consulter la
source principale d'information de vos
élèves c'est quoi moi je suis très
heureuse que qu'on commençait à parler
de ça parce que c'est vraiment la base
connaître les sources d'information et
récemment la joueur demandé d'aller
chercher des définitions et je leur ai
dit dites moi dans quelle source vous
allez retrouver et toujours j'ai
toujours un élève qui aime dire un la
source et internet ou bien si google est
donc charge à nous d'en expliquer
vraiment c'est pas ça une source
d'information c'est beaucoup plus précis
il faut qu'elles soient indiqués avec
une présentation claire quand ya pas de
sources conseiller anonyme quand ses
boutons il faut pas s'y fier et dès que
ça c'est très vraiment très important de
préciser avec on travaille effectivement
en classe régulièrement et j'ai oublié
votre question de départ quelles étaient
les sources d'information vite c'est
plutôt le sait alors clairement leurs
réflexes ça va pas l'être d'aller vers
l'écrit éventuellement encore un petit
peu par exemple sur des définitions
quelques-uns des dictionnaires papier
mais c'est quand même pas très frais
courants ils vont sur ils vont sur
internet ils vont pas forcément sur les
réseaux sociaux ils vont sur internet
il tape dans un moteur de recherche et
puis souvent des phrases entières en
plus et puis prennent les premiers liens
donc là aussi on a un gros travail à
faire valoir leur expliquer comment s'en
faut cela dit il ya ya ya le pire et le
meilleur sur internet et aussi des
classes des choses vraies vincent
couronne par exemple bon on peut trouver
votre pour trouver vos surligneurs sur
internet par ex au flop c'est pas y a
pas que des mauvaises choses et mêmes et
même cette émission en replay
cette émission va dire la qualité
parfois l'internet mais vous avez raison
jean-charles et maryse de parler de la
question des sources
en fait la diffusion et le regain du
complotisme s'explique aussi par un
phénomène en fait qui est qui et comment
dire qui est nouveau en tout cas qui
date d'une petite dizaine d'années
qu'est ce qu'on appelle en fait le
nouveau marché de l'information alors
qu'est ce que c'est ce nouveau marché
l'information c'est le fait qu' il ya
une massification d'informations
disponibles on le voit bien les partout
sur internet sur les réseaux sociaux etc
il y a aussi le fait qu'avec nos
smartphones nous ayons des notifications
en permanence qui captent notre
attention
il ferait économie de l'attention de la
part des des grandes entreprises de la
silicon valley et en captant notre
attention en fait systématiquement en
longueur de journée nous empêche de
réfléchir de nous concentrer
suffisamment longuement sur des sujets
combinons cela avec le fait que et bien
notre cerveau nous simplement pas en
mesure d'assimiler avec un regard
critique tout ce qu'il reçoit qui classe
les infos landais dans des cases qui
sont préfabriqués c'est ce qu'on appelle
un des préjugés anciens mécanismes
totalement naturelle mais évidemment on
essaye souvent de combattre cette
massification d'information avec le
renforcement des préjugés notamment %
pour certains les théories du complot
fait qu'on a un retour de ces théories
un regain de ces théories du complot
contre lesquels en fait en réalité pour
pouvoir lutter il faut effectivement
réapprendre aux jeunes comment lire
l'information et ça passe par ça passe
par l'étude des sources
peut-être est-ce que au fond n'est pas
et c'est une source d information trop
informés aujourd'hui il ya des dessins
d'info continue on a l'impression que
les événements sont tous importants tous
au même niveau puisqu'il faut un
événement chaque jour pour nourrir
l'actualité
est-ce que trop d'informations au fond
ça tu parles la véritable information
trop d'impôt tué l'impôt
mais cette rhétorique que pour le mérite
d'être resté mais je sais pas non bien
sûr que c'est vrai mais les cerqueux on
part on parle des jeunes alors je les
jeunes mois fin je me sens inclus quand
on parle des jeunes et d'autre part la
fécondation où passe la frontière mais
je pense que c'est tout allez les
habituels les adultes n'ont pas pour ne
fréquente que très peu la presse écrite
regarder les chiffres varient de la
presse écrite en france par rapport à
d'autres cultures à d'autres pays
peut-être peut-être pour une part de
responsabilité sans doute enfin
probablement mais il n'y a pas une
culture de la lecture dans ces pays où
la puissance des organes de presse dans
certaines grandes démocraties et puis
alors trop d'informations pas forcément
qu'est ce que voulez moi je je ne
regarde pas la télévision
mais je pense que c'est à la télévision
que les choses socialement sont les plus
les plus manifestes les chaînes d'info
continue qui ont été créés je ne sais
pas du butin des années 90 et enfin de
bus début des années 2000 enfin c'est
c'en est presque parfois comique parce
qu on allait dire on peine parfois pour
le journaliste qui est la rame et a
essayé d'occuper l'espace sonore et des
coûts d'occuper l'espace visuel avec d
infondées des images qui passent en
boucle qui sont pas sans rappeler le
presque le cinéma muet si vous voulez et
puis avec des experts autoproclamés qui
sait pas ce qu'il faut meubler parce
qu'on voulait occuper l'espace sonore l
espace visuel espace visuel ya un truc
qui me fait toujours rire moi c'est toi
c'est quelque chose tous les sens quand
il passe quelque chose à l'elysée il met
toujours nationaliste sur le trottoir
d'en face de l'endroit où on est le
moins informé il veut venir et vous avez
vous avez parfois je sais pas 2,3
parfois plus bandeau qui qui qui qui
sont à incruster en même temps avait
avec les cours de la bourse en haut à
gauche avec l'actualité brûlante bas à
droite la météo le oui l'important quoi
oui l'essentiel c'est ça qui compte
je pense qu il
vraie confusion entre l'info et le buzz
et je pense qu'il y a tout c'est toutes
ces chaînes bfm tv extra ce qu'ils
veulent c'est faire du buzz
avoir avoir des spectateurs et et faire
un bon audimat et donc c'est entretenir
du buzz et du bruit autour d'un certain
nombre d'informations qui finalement
n'ont peut-être pas grand intérêt ou qui
peuvent être dit et analysés en dix
minutes plutôt que de passer la journée
dessus et alors sur le complotisme si je
peux dire un mot par rapport à ma
profession puisqu'il ya aussi des
notions de complot à plusieurs reprises
pendant mon pendant mon expérience souci
pardon et cki quand une personne perd
son procès et c'est que c'est un complot
et c'est que notamment en matière
commerciale
il ya des chefs d'entreprise qu'ils
disent mais en fait le juge qui hakim a
jugé finalement il est en contact avec
des concurrents et donc les concurrents
par le juge pour que je perde mon gré
celle où
donc voilà c'est assez compliqué enfin
bon je passe du temps alors expliqué que
non les juges sont censés être
impartiaux et d'analyser les dossiers
qu'ils ont et on voit au travers des
décisions que il ya des motivations qui
sont réelles et ne ça vient pas oui mais
ça fait d'argent rescue me disais c'est
que dans l'est dans certains quartiers
où des jeunes se sentent mis à la marge
mais là c'est pareil c'est une réaction
de vie de victimes entre guillemets pour
l'édification victimisation pour pouvoir
avaler la la le procès perdu en se
disant que c'est son dossier était bon
mais c'est la faute du juge
je suis tout à fait d'accord en fait
souvent le complotisme een hellas
lorsqu'on ne veut pas admettre la
réalité ou lorsqu'on a pas de vérité à
laquelle se fier et donc du coup c'est
très très inconfortable c'est pas du
tout rassurant ne pas connaître la
vérité ou d'admettre vérité une réalité
qui est qui et traumatique qui s'il a
accepté et c'est là souvent que pour ne
pas avoir accepté une réalité difficile
on va imaginer des scénarios parce que
c'est plus des synagogues des théories
d'ailleurs souvent les histoires de
british c'est des histoires un peu
fictive qu'on avance parce qu'on a du
mal avec la réalité et la vérité en fait
c'est souvent la claque on connaît le
connaît le complotisme mais en fait non
pas oui justement moi souvent des
clients me disent que de toute façon la
justice est manipulé par les
francs-maçons un complot à son coeur de
nice qui a dit à peu près la même sauce
a besoin de montgolfier ne semble pas y
aller mais regrette justement sur ces
infos qui se répandent alors moi j'ai
encore dû deux choses déjà par rapport
aux représentations qui sont véhiculées
moi je pense pas que la télévision soit
le principal vecteur il suffit de
regarder les chiffres de l'audimat
aujourd'hui à la télévision
globalement et pour je veux pas être
trop caricatural mais c'est à dire un
média de plus de 60 ans la télévision a
clairement que les jeunes ne la regarde
assez peu en dehors des chaînes
d'information continue et là je parlerai
une expérience qui concerne uniquement
les quartiers prioritaires mais dans les
quartiers critères on a beaucoup de
cafés de maisons de maisons de jeunes et
c'est systématiquement quand vous entrez
dans ce genre d'établissement vous avez
fm qui tourne en boucle et donc on tape
le carton jaune au baby foot on en
discute le coup en regardant des films
télé et c'est à peu près la seule la
seule consommation de média télévisuel
qu'on peut avoir en tout cas pour une
population qui voilà qui aurait moins de
50 ans pour pas aller trop loin
après pour le coup je travaille
personnellement sur un projet de
sourcing justement des interlocuteurs
des quartiers avec bfm tv et
l'association des maires ville et
banlieue
bfmtv aujourd'hui j'ai la conscience de
sa et mène une vraie réflexion aussi
pour avoir une approche peut-être plus
plus juste plus équilibrée aussi de la
réalité des territoires qui sont qui
sont très clairement pour parler des
quartiers populaires en tout cas l'objet
de tous les fantasmes parce que
évidemment la représentation que peu à
voir les jeunes des quartiers sur sur la
société en général il ya aussi la les
représentation fantasmée que la société
peut se faire sur sur ces quartiers qui
concerne 20 8% de la population
nationale
on va peut-être il ya juste une chose
qui était intéressant peut-être jean
charles une règle sur la dessus vous
parliez du buzz dans les dents les dents
les chaînes d'information continue et
ses news justement qui a monté beaucoup
son audience grâce à beaucoup de buzz on
vient d'apprendre qu'au faubel les
publicitaires ne suivait pas c'est assez
intéressant
à force de faire du buzz et finalement
les publicitaires sont un peu gênés
aussi par par certaines émissions
toujours du buzz
vous avez une réaction est là dessus
peut-être jean-charles oui donc de mons
ou trouble assez injuste avec les
chaînes d'information qui ont quand même
le mérite de délivrer de l'information
rappeler quand même que ces chaînes
d'information en continu ne sont pas
faites pour être regardé en continu donc
si je ne connais personne qui regarde 12
l'an 2 suit avec attention
rémy et c'est comme ça on peut la voir
c'est comme semblent le dire stéphane
qui nous dit qu'ils regardent pas la
télévision mais qui nous décrit des
scènes tdk luxe de précision qui est at
il pas temps il s'est même trouvé place
et indices 'l'indice bourse il se dit
chapeau à quelqu'un qui ne la regarde
pas il a dû sauver cette dépression mais
un an + plus sérieusement c'est moi je
suis comme beaucoup plus rassurés de
voir les zones regarder bfm ces news lci
ou n'importe quelle scène d'informations
qu'un robinet à clips pour regarder des
rappeurs entouré de femmes dans des jeux
pan impose de viol voilà honnêtement
c'est c'est pas mal de cette info bien
évidemment c'est perfectible mais c'est
quand même de l'information
il ya des défauts à ces chaises mais
mais c'est quand même bien vincent grog
oui juste un mot je suis d'accord sur le
fait que aujourd'hui on regarde comment
la télévision qu'auparavant mais mais je
pense qu'il faut pas non plus diminuer
le rôle que c'est ces chaînes on entend
que qu'élément prescripteurs sur
l'information
il y avait une étude qui avait été fait
à l'époque des attentats de charlie
hebdo qu'on est en pleine actualité si
vous en parlez pour essayer depuis de
ces deux tracés des théories du complot
à l'époque cette attente à l'heure en
réalité on s'était rendu compte ces
chercheurs la s'était rendu compte que
c'était souvent un tweet qui avait
commencé repris y ont semé mais que
personne n'avait vraiment partager votre
petit contrat très suivie repris par une
chaîne d'information continue et là en
fait la formation est beaucoup plus
visible et revient ensuite sur twitter
pour pour se transformer en théorie du
complot ou virales et c est pourquoi
parce que il ya eu cette validation
d'information de ce tweet isolés par une
chaîne d'information continue et même si
pas grand monde a vu au final sur les
chaînes d'info il n'empêche que ça crée
une théorie du complot
donc voilà c'est simplement je pense
qu'il faut il faut il faut il faut
comprendre ce mécanisme là et pour pour
essayer d'aider des compactes c'est à
dire qu'effectivement le tweet arrive
bfm reprend il ya un contexte et une
ambiance médiatique qui s'installe au
moment des attentats évidemment on est
dans une ambiance médiatique
totalement hystérique tout le monde est
branché sur la télé c'est comme avant et
cristaux bleus en septembre
aujourd'hui le coc vide je pense que
beaucoup de gens aussi suivre ça à la
télévision parce que ça devient le média
un peu rassurant aussi pendant prendre
comme vous dites c'est un média qui
valide aussi un moment l'information et
c'est là qu'on va chercher la vérité
quelque part dans les camps tant
d'incertitudes donc c'était je crois
madame madame madame madame mercadé non
madame broustal kibaki parler de ça
effectivement
la notion d'incertitude allez allez
allez très importante voire très présent
totalement voici très rapidement à peut
décrypter ce que c'est le complotistes
décryptage justement là il ya une chose
qui m'amuse et beauté j'ai repris les
les les faits que news qui ont ils plus
du succès et je suis en cité comme ça
vous vous demandez pourquoi votre avis
et l'étendue du succès d'abord il ya
tous ceux qui sont à bord elvis presley
est évidemment qui est toujours en vie à
michael jackson il ya marilyn monroe
aussi hitler lui même se porte bien ce
serait un blindé allemande marlene monde
pourquoi votre avis à ce barça c'est
l'attachement à des idoles c'est que ça
s'est beaucoup ça ça n'a pas envie de
voir mourir
et puis en plus c'est des personnages un
peu sulfureux qu'on connaît une
formation physique me pourrait se cacher
simuler leur père mort pour être un peu
tranquille mais là c'est pas c'est pas
des théories qui sont très dangereuses
quoi c'est plutôt rigolo en fait oui oui
ça j'ai dit oui cela amusant oui pardon
il ya quand même bien pire parce que
tout ça c'est assez comique mais il ya
quand même aussi beaucoup de gens qui
pensent encore que la terre est plate
donc là ça me paraît être l'un des clous
de absolue donc oui et les plates east
mais mais mais ça est-ce que c'est du
complotisme mousse et de la croyance
enfin c'est compliqué à sa place dans la
formation mais c'est des gens qui
croient qu enfin
ce qui est vraiment inquiétant il ya les
plates east et puis il ya les anti
vaccins en fait ce qui est très
inquiétant en ce moment c'est que le
domaine le plus sensible sur les thèmes
des informations et de comploter succès
la science c'est la science et ce qui
est compliqué c'est que il faut pas être
dans le fond pour décrypter en fait le
complotisme qui ce qui est lié à la
science parce que il faut être expert
pouvoir être il faut vraiment travailler
la forme c'est à dire regardez comment
les informations à caractère
scientifique sont diffusées regardez qui
est l'auteur d'un livre qui sort qui
sort là dessus sur justement la
désinformation en matière scientifique
et bm l'influencent parfois des lobbys
aussi qui voilà qui donne des phrases
toutes faites à des journalistes et
voilà qu'on trouve après dans des
articles dans des des éditos à la
télévision et qui sont en réalité
totalement fausses bardot sur le sur la
coved je pense aussi qu'ils s'appuient
sur toutes les incertitudes
le tâtonnement du gouvernement au début
de la crise
bien sûr il ya des masques en fait y'a
pas de masque il faut mettre des masques
faut pas mettre des masques faut rester
confiné maintenant des confine les
enfants ne sont pas porteurs maintenant
ils sont porteurs et je pense que du
coup ça donne un peu d'eau à leur moulin
en disant nous dit absolument n'importe
quoi alors que effectivement elite y
patauge parce que la commune a été fait
par les laboratoires exception à cette
rumeur la cavac et qui est assez forte
le coroner virus le sida vont là on vous
l'avait dit de la même façon a été créée
par des laboratoires ça c'est un truc
qui est assez répandu un notre croyance
enfin des informations est assez répandu
et rémy en vendant à l'aplomb d'un
sentiment c'est intéressant parce qu'à
la fin le complotisme c'est toujours
quelque part et il ne vaut une rébellion
contre une situation où contre un ordre
établi
là aujourd'hui on a le phénomène des
antilles masque m
mine de rien de plus en plus de poids
j'ai moi-même été interpellé le maire de
chanteloup l'avap tard que la semaine
dernière par une mère qui dépend des
goûts vraiment contre l'obligation fort
telle masse
donc oui dans ce genre de situation ou
extrêmement anxiogènes je crois qu'il ya
une espèce de deux phénomènes un peu
naturel
il ya des personnes qui vont s'appuyer
là dessus et puis du coup jouer david
contre goliath est enceinte et en en
faisant feu de tout bois à quelque part
et donc ça va être demain les vaccins
banon je voudrais pas de vaccin parce
que forcément ces vaccins la semoy
seront certainement vecteur d'effets
secondaires qui rendront encore plus
malade ça va être je peux pas mettre le
masque
ça va être je sais pas demain le gel et
aux alcooliques qui va nous certainement
nous pourrir la peau des mains va j'en
sais rien il ya il ya tout un tas de
deux théories qui pourront qui pourront
circuler mais on le voit je restais là
c'est concret notamment sur le port du
masque
j'en ai parlé de moi même avec des
collègues qui travaillent soit dans
d'autres collectivités soient fondées
parlementaire qui me confirme bien qu'à
une tendance en augmentation aujourd'hui
sur sur sur le sujet à mai à
décrédibiliser le port du masque et
demain certainement vous aurez des
actions en justice enfin voila il va y
avoir des oui il ya toute une théorie
qui pensent qu'elle est sa prospère
aussi sur les réseaux sociaux avec des
gens qui vous disent mais attendez ce
que je vous dis c'est vrai c'est validé
par le ms il ya énormément de discours
qui circulent et qui utilisent
l'argument d'autorité mais moi je je je
pose la question mais où êtes vous allé
chercher cette information il me semble
que changer totalement le terme du débat
c'est à dire que très honnêtement on
peut remettre en question l'utilité et
le port du masque dans certains endroits
sans pour autant être complotistes n' y
ait quoi que ce soit médicalement c'est
à dire qu'il ya fondé vous semblez
confondre il ya bientôt dix ans le
disque hot legs ont peu envie de parler
ainsi masquer radicaux si je veux dire
voilà c'est ça c'est dommage que parent
malade mais l'enfant c'est ça qu'on nous
dire et le basque part en balade mes
enfants
on n'a pas encore le finalement la
perspective d'un retour ni historique de
savoir si ça rendra les gens plus malade
ou pas donc là ce qu'on vous raconte
c'est que le basque demain pourra vous
comment dire vous faire souffrir de
difficultés respiratoires par exemple
donc
donc on n'est pas on est quand même mine
de rien dans le champ qu'on est en train
de travailler là tous ensemble et pas
juste quand est ce qu'il est et ce qu'il
est pertinent de le mettre à telle heure
à tel endroit
ce n'est pas ça qu'on dira pour conclure
sur sa table s'est fait mention est-ce
qu'il n'y a pas un lien finalement vous
avez il ya une grande mode de l'anti
politiquement correct qui dit que de
dire on ne peut pas tout dire et et le
complotisme sait on nous dit pas tout il
n'y a pas un lien entre les deux
finalement oui mais ça ça a été dit je
pense que c'est aussi adhérer à des
informations manipulées ou à des thèses
complotistes tenté de ce prêtre de se
singulariser de chez eux de se
distinguer mais au sens dans un sens
inverse d'une stigmatisation
c'est à dire de dire moi je suis je
j'appartiens au groupe qui sait et donc
je me sens je sais que je sais et les
autres ne savent pas cc c'est sans doute
il ya une espèce de de retournement de
situation de compensation et puis
fondamentalement aussi on a parlé d
habitude de la culture de l'information
etc
tout à l'heure c'est c'est tellement il
ya une forme de paresse de l'esprit
aussi on a un truc touchait tout prêt à
penser qu'ils s'appuient parfois sur des
dogmes des choses simpliste c'est
tellement simple c'est du prêt-à-penser
bon ben voilà jalousie allons-y j'adopte
ça et puis j'ai pas besoin de me creuser
les méninges où je n'ai pas besoin de
douter parce qu'on s'appuie là sur des
ces questions scientifiques
fondamentales la vérité c'est que pour
beaucoup de choses on ne sait pas et que
le doute fait pourtant partie de
intrinsèquement de la démarche douter un
on a très peur du doute aujourd'hui mais
dès lors qu'il est dès lors qu'il est
méthodique le doute est indispensable et
le fait de ne pas savoir apparaît
insupportable absolument alors on va
finir avec ce thème parce que je
voudrais profiter justement de la
présence de d'une enseignante
d'enseignés plusieurs animaux dit non
c'est non du secondaire avec nous pour
parler d'un thème dont on a beaucoup
parlé cette semaine c'est la tenue des
délits scène
voilà c'est le thème des 10 c est
justement alors c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
ce mouvement odile 14 sep qui prône la
la liberté de tenue des notamment des
filles 1 ça ne concerne plus les filles
que les garçons c'est intéressant
d'ailleurs dans les lycées est-ce que
vous avez un point de vue d'ailleurs
là-dessus est ce que vous vous dites
dans un lycée moi j'avais une
comparaison qui vaut ce qu'elle vaut
mais il ya il ya au fond la laïcité
indique par exemple qu'on ne met pas de
signes de religieux voyons est-ce que
vous pourrez pas dire après tout que
sexualisation trop voyants tout être un
peu neutre ou est ce que vous dites
après tout don fait ce qu'on veut moi je
pense que la tenue c'est pas forcément
dans le problème le problème c'est
d'éduquer correctement les filles et les
garçons à l'égalité entre les filles et
les garçons avoir des jugements des
juifs à ne pas avoir des jugements
préconçus donc et fils est un problème
qui est quand même très récurrents il
clermont sur lequel on glisse sans arrêt
à mon avis c'est là tu ne sais pas ça le
problème c'est vraiment l'éducation à
l'égalité entre les sexes
voilà c'est ça et on est en travaillant
ça avec les élèves oui parce que le rat
- le problème est moins jugement
peut-être sur les tenues qui sont trop
longs trop courte
encore une fois c'est un flic dans un
problème de tenue
le regard des garçons sur les filles 1
et défier sont les filles aussi un dvd
regarde maintenant général c'est ça en
fait peut-être regard sexualisé des
garçons aussi enfin il ya quand même ça
c'est du côté des actifs cédés sont pas
décents etc c'est quand même question
compliquée parce que si vous utilisez le
terme de sexualité ça prouve bien qu'ils
ont met en opposition les garçons et des
filles quand ils ne peuvent pas si un
garçon mais à chaque personne va même
très court en personne va lui dire quoi
que ce soit du petit machin quand tv le
truc qui dépassait de quel seuil est
dépassé le short un moment sur les gars
on savait faire un petit un petit débat
d'entre-deux dans les établissements
d'enseignement rémy au grand justement
est-ce que vaille et des endroits où on
peut s'habiller comme on veut et des
endroits où on ne peut pas s'habiller
comme on veut vous posez la question à
vous poser la question concernant des
des quartiers comme un chant tout bien
oui ma raison par exemple
dites moi oui elle semble ou par exemple
on a écouté je pense que oui a
certainement un conformisme un
conformisme de la tenue vestimentaire
qui peut s'exprimer à certains endroits
après honnêtement pas plus tard qu'hier
j'étais en rendez vous à la région
ile-de-france et et on a pu on a pu me
faire partager avec moi
plusieurs indicateurs qui permettait
justement de regarder le regarder en
fonction des quartiers
par exemple dans les réunions le
la proportion de femmes qui portent le
voile etc nous achevons de folie vide je
peux vous dire que fêter réunion au
centre social
on reste quand même sur sur une une
mixité absolue des populations avec
beaucoup de femmes qui ont des tenues
vestimentaires très différente alors
j'ai envie de vous dire tout ça dépend
des territoires d'un quartier à un autre
on va pas avoir la même emprise ici
aussi le sujet dont vous êtes en train
de parler c'est aussi le conformisme
religieux ou confessionnelle il peut y
avoir des territoires effectivement sur
lesquels sur lesquels on verse dans ce
que président de la république nomme le
séparatisme et que et que ce séparatisme
s'exprime aussi de manière vestimentaire
et jeudi très honnêtement je suis même
pas en tant que communiquant au service
de la ville de chanteloup les vignes
mais c'est assez mal cas à chanteloup
les vignes ont la chance d'avoir un
territoire qui est relativement préservé
aussi des phénomènes doré de
radicalisation contre la radicalisation
ben c'est pas le cas partout c'est pas
le cas partout et on va avoir parfois
des territoires même des très petits
territoires qui vont être sous influence
de l'espace confessionnelles connus ou
pas d'ailleurs qui vont qui vont du coup
on a imprimé une forme de conformisme
notamment restent immenses terres alors
après quand on a dit ça on n'a rien dit
sur sur le reste puisqu'en fait 90% de
de la réponse à votre question réside
sur une population qui mène pas
concernés par ce que je viens d'écrire
donc pour vous répondre moi je vois des
jeunes en tout cas si on parle des
jeunes chantent ou les lignes de choix
des jeunes qui sont habillés de toutes
les façons avec certainement par contre
un conformisme qui est lié à ce qu'on
peut voir dans les robinet à clips
décrit par monsieur lajoinie c'est à
dire une culture urbaine culture hip hop
une tenue vestimentaire qui va plutôt
être calqué sur les stars de la chanson
de la télévision beaucoup plus que sur
les codes vestimentaires liée à un
quelconque religion trois mois
florence woerth avait apporté une photo
j'aimerais bien qu'on la voit qu'ils
donnent des 60 70 78 est ce qu'on est
devenu un peu plus niveau de pluie bat
écoutez là je trouve que l'on pourrait
retrouver nos jeunes d'aujourd'hui qui
qui sont habillés de cette façon là donc
deux états unis l'ont dit ça je pense
que c'était aux états unis mais c'est la
même chose je pense que c'était la même
chose en france mais je voulais juste
dire une chose par rapport à cette
histoire d'habillement je peux plus
avait dû entendre cette jeune fille qui
a été voilà qui a été attaquée parce
qu'elle portait une jupe
les agresseurs ont été condamnés
condamné à une peine de six mois
d'emprisonnement et également à faire du
travail d'intérêt général et notamment à
réfléchir sur sur cette évolution et sur
la relation égalitaire entre les hommes
et des femmes
enfin devenir rapidement parce qu'il
nous reste à peine une minute
mais rapidement sur avis que florence
mercadet et parler ces agressions de
deux filles en jupe et à strasbourg et
puis ailleurs en france et que ce
problème de l'un d'eux la tenue
vestimentaire en milieu scolaire elle
est important parce que si on cède
encore une fois là dessus ce sera la
porte ouverte à après une espèce de
d'uniformisation et de dire bon on ne va
pas choqué a billion tout le monde de la
même façon recommandons le port du
pantalon qu'on ne pas choquer les
quelques élèves qui sont affolés par la
vision d'un genou alors j'ai des lycéens
ou des filles ont remis l'uniforme par
exemple un préconiserait préconise la
lune boxer c'est un recul quand même
aussi simple c'est juste comme le dit
malade plus que les garçons
éduquons les garçons éduquons les fuit
parce que entre fixe et aussi terré de
nombreuses filles traitent les autres de
traîner à partir du moment où certaines
sont habillés de façon un tout petit peu
de légères et c'est ça qu'est ce qu'on
appelle c'est encore une fois uniquement
un problème d'éducation et de et de
sévérité envers les délinquants de la
parole et quelquefois vous n'êtes pas
que pour la tenue normale comme le
médecin délégation nationale
il nous reste plus de temps je voulais
parler dans le livre vous avez trente
secondes après donc c'est un livre qui a
été écrit par une jeune fille qu'à 24
ans qui s'appelle marine sans clémente
et catherine fait elles sont parties
toutes les deux en mauritanie sur les
traces de vous laver à l'écran sur les
traces de deux femmes qui en 1933 son
arrivée sur un langoustier en mauritanie
et qui ont parcouru la mauritanie toutes
les deux et donc elles sont partis sur
les traces de ces deux dames pour
essayer de retrouver exactement les
endroits où elle sera les et c'est très
intéressant c'est extrêmement bien écrit
dont je vous le conseille pas ce que ça
y est on est parti en mauritanie nous
ferons connaître les paysages les lieux
de vie et les deux largement posée sur
la joie non je suis désolé c'est aux
éditions pol scène et je vous conseille
cette lecture merci merci beaucoup merci
vous couvrir mon style et j'espère qu'on
aura l'occasion de vous revoir souvent
parce que c'est intéressant de ce
travail que vous menez avec les les
enfants merci beaucoup réduit ont
renversé vos conférences mercadet souk
et stéphane minson vincent couronne et
jean charles lajoie ni à très vite pour
un nouveau numéro de paf
[Musique]